hey hi there Steve Kaufman here I'm in
sunny Palm Springs the weather is very
warm ninety to a hundred in there
Fahrenheit which is up there on 35
degrees centigrade or something today I
want to talk about a subject that comes
up all the time and it's in response to
a question that I received from a person
writing in Russian from Russia and the
question was you know how do you get to
where you can think in the language
you're learning and this person was
saying that I think it's a she she was
learning and you know knows a lot of
words and stuff but she always ends up
translating from Russian into English
because the language is so different and
so forth and how do you get to where you
think in the language so this is in
response to her and because it's a
subject that comes up all the time so
let me just say up front I never think
about the question of whether I'm
translating from English into another
language or not it's not something that
is an item of concern to me I realize
that in all the languages that I'm
learning or that I have learned or that
I speak and it's always a mixture of
some things that we say naturally in the
language and some things that we are
subconsciously or even deliberately
translating from either our own language
or related language that we know very
very well so to me in learning a
language my main goal is to increase my
vocabulary the words and phrases that I
know in the new language that's what I
work on and I acquired these words and
phrases largely through listening and
reading and to some extent reviewing
them and the more words and phrases that
I have the more natural the better my
understanding my comprehension the more
interesting things I'm able to listen to
and the more these words and phrases
become part of me now
if I think of certain languages okay
obviously the structure of a new
language very often is different from
the structure of our own language so
while we for certain you know difficult
words we may think of the word you know
comprehension or you know predisposition
or something like that we may think of
it first in our own language and then
search for it in the new language but
for a lot of the things that we want to
say we start to adopt the phrasing of
the target language so if we take the
case of Russian for example if I were to
say it seems to me I would say Mia casa
mia casa it seems to me but that's very
Russian that's that you can't be saying
that in frazzling it's something you get
used to saying it's like you know in in
Japanese very often people to give
themselves time to to respond to a
question they might just say mmm door
they show commands for this name which
just is nothing really that oh okay I
see and so you start saying these things
you know in Chinese yeah Jago bow tie
Yoga booty Arjun it's not to him I don't
know you end up with these sort of
natural phrases that pop out if you
heard them often enough but there's
nothing wrong with attaching the
learning of a new language to a language
you already know we need to associate
the new words and new phrases with a
corresponding word or phrase and a
language that we know that's how we
first acquire the new word or phrase we
learned that this is how they say it in
this language and I have always said
that I always even in a language that I
know very well I prefer a bilingual
dictionary because it gives me an
immediate suggestion as to the meaning
of a new word that I encounter and yet I
don't have any real confidence that I
know that word or that I can use that
word until I see the word in many many
more contexts so that first look
in a dictionary it's just a hint to get
me going it's no more than that and so I
don't need a lengthy explanation in the
target language I find it easier if I
can connect it to the language that I
already know usually my own language and
so to the extent that if I'm explaining
some difficult concept in some language
and I'm relying to some extent on
vocabulary that I know from my own
language I don't see that there's
anything particularly wrong about that
and and I don't think really that we
know at least I don't ever have the
sense that I know if I am translating
from English or if I am relying on sort
of natural new habits that I have
created in in the new language I don't
even worry about it it doesn't come up
my concern and I'm going to show you
sort of a graph of my Arabic on the
graphs that we now have it linked
showing the growth of my vocabulary this
is all I worry about I also to some
extent I can't say that right now I'm
worrying about it in Arabic because I
don't speak very much but say in Slavic
languages this what crashing refers to
me as the effective filter that sense of
insecurity when you don't know if you've
got the right case ending or you know if
you're using the subjunctive and to say
some other languages where you
second-guess yourself those are the
things that bothered me when I was peaky
that rather than just going with what I
would be naturally naturally inclined to
say I try and second-guess myself refer
back to grammar rules which is actually
not a good thing to do but I do confess
that I do that and that inhibits my
speaking but as for worrying about
whether I translate from English or
don't translate from English I don't
worry about it I am sure that the
languages that I speak the best I do
less of it the language that I don't
speak so well I do more of it it
probably helps me in many grammatical
situations the most common everyday
expressions I think we more quickly move
into a situation or we're just
using the natural you know expressions
and phrases of the new language and when
we get into more complicated situations
we may rely on you know a reference to
our own language and a translation I
really don't see that as a problem
so I be very interested in your comments
because it comes up all the time and
hopefully this also answers the question
that I receive from someone in Russia so
thank you for listening and you know
next week at this time I will have been
in Buenos Aires for three days we're
starting to get some people together for
a meeting in Buenos Aires maybe on the
3rd of October which would be the guys I
don't have in front of me the third is
that Wednesday it might be and hopefully
I'll meet some people are going to save
it and and then from there we go I'm
going to Mendoza for 340 days back to
Buenos Aires then I going to he was su
from he goes to to Rio I spend a few
days in Rio from Rio to Salvador from
Salvador back to Rio then to Lima then
to my to Picchu back to Lima for a few
more days and then returning home on the
29th of October so thank you for
listening bye for now
[Music]